NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Let's start off a quick
list of important concepts
for the week.
Just-- and I'm going to
push you right along today.
I want to get this done.
What do you got?
AUDIENCE: Static
Equilibrium positions?
PROFESSOR: Static
equilibrium, OK.
So EOMs from xstatic.
OK, good.
Another concept for the week?
AUDIENCE: Damping.
PROFESSOR: Damping, yeah.
And what have we've been
talking about all week?
AUDIENCE: Vibration.
PROFESSOR: Vibration.
OK.
So vibration, damping, OK.
More?
What's the whole general subject
that we've encased vibration
in?
It's an introduction to what?
Have to make it.
We've been making an assumption
that we haven't made before.
Yeah, linear.
We've been studying--
this has been
an intro to-- linear systems.
We can only do things
like transfer functions,
that sort of thing,
by assuming linearity.
Anything else?
What have I just spent the last
two lectures deriving for you
and showing you?
Transfer functions.
In fact, I've shown you three.
All right?
All right.
That's beginning to get at
what we've been talking about.
So introduction
to linear systems.
We've been studying vibration
as one implementation
or application of
linear systems.
We've been looking at single
degree of freedom vibration
problems only so far.
And we've found frequency
response functions.
These frequency response
function tell you
the response of the system
to what kind of an input?
What are the
characteristics of the input
that we've been looking at?
What do we call harmonics?
Single frequency cosine
omega t-like input.
Cosine omega t, sine
omega t, e the i omega t.
One frequency, repetitive,
it's called a harmonic input.
So for a linear system--
we've also we're
talking about what we call
the steady state response.
What's that mean?
OK.
Put that into words.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So you
turn the motor on,
the whole building
shakes, settles down,
and just has a steady
vibration you're dealing with.
So after any startup
transients have died out,
it's the steady state response.
If you have a linear system
and you're putting in some F0
e to the i omega t force, a real
part of steady state response,
what is the frequency
of the response?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So for linear systems,
the steady state response,
the frequency of
the output always
it's a property of
a linear system.
So a couple really important
things to remember here.
Good.
Now we're going to move
onto a problem-- Oh.
And then one other thing
I usually do-- ask of you,
is are there any
major questions?
Something left
over from lecture.
Something we've done
in the last week
that just isn't going down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
gravity [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: How do
you get gravity
to go away in the equation?
Actually, this is the
most common question
that's been asked to the
TA's this week, of Professor
Gossard, of me.
So there still seems to be a
little bit of misunderstanding
about-- and this is the
subject of static equilibrium,
verses unstretched
spring kind of positions.
I think I'll just deal
with that right away.
You're familiar
with this problem?
K, C, M. And most of you are
comfortable with the notion
of measuring x from
the unstretched spring
position, right?
So that's what I've
done right here.
Now you add gravity though,
and let it find its equilibrium
position under
gravity, it's going
to be at some other location.
And I'm just going
to call that xstatic.
Static displacement.
Now when you turn on
the harmonic excitation,
or even grab it and let it
go from initial condition,
where will it vibrate around?
It's going to vibrate around
the static equilibrium position.
Here's my system.
Here's my free body diagram.
Got all the gravities and Cx's
and Kx's and x dots and so
forth in it complete, right?
I can write an
equation of motion
for that system, which
you've done lots of times.
And it has a gravity in it.
But now I'm going to say
look, here's my x-coordinate,
it stretches down xstatic.
And on top of that I'm going
to add a little dynamic motion.
And I'm going to describe that
as x equals xstatic a constant,
plus the dynamic movement
with respect to xstatic.
Take the time derivative of
it, because this is constant.
It goes away.
And two time derivative.
So x dot is x dot
d, and x double dot
is x double dot, the
dynamic quantity.
Take these three and
plug them into here.
Mxd double dot, Cxd dot.
But the K term, you
still have xstatic in it.
The original Kx breaks
into two pieces.
And on the right hand side is
my Mg plus f of t, like before.
But K xstatic must
be equal to Mg
in order for static
equilibrium to have existed.
Everybody agree with that?
Another way say that is let's
say there's no dynamic motion.
This term goes away.
Turn off the excitation.
You're left with
that equals this.
And that's what says it sits
in the static equilibrium
position.
If those two are equal, they
cancel, leaving you with this.
So if you had understood
this in the beginning,
you could have said let's
make our inertial coordinate
from the static
equilibrium position.
Just let the thing find its
static equilibrium position,
set the inertia coordinate
measured from there,
and you would get
to this equation,
with the possible
confusion of having to deal
with the free body diagram.
Because the free
body diagram still
has on it Mg and the
spring force that
comes from the static position.
So if I were doing
this, and just
say I want to go directly
to this equation,
I would draw the free
body diagram that
would have Kxd Cxd dot, F MG,
but then I would also just
put in here-- there's
one more force.
K times xstatic or delta or
whatever you want to call it.
You know there's
some xstatic, and you
know-- because you're
doing this-- you
know this about the problem.
You know this cancels
that, and it won't appear
in the equation of motion.
So to be able to do--
anytime you're confronted
with a problem that has
gravity, which causes
a static deflection, or
results in a static equilibrium
position, it might be 0 in
your coordinate-like pendulum.
You look at it, and you say,
now in the equation of motion
that you derived from the
unstretched spring force
position is the
Mg term a function
of the motion coordinate?
And in this case it is not.
So it doesn't matter
what x becomes,
this force stays constant.
It doesn't enter into the
dynamics of the problem.
If you ever write an
equation of motion,
and you come to an Mg term that
doesn't have a theta or an x
or any variable in it, you
know that there's another way
to write that equation
about static equilibrium,
and you'll be able
to get rid of it,
and simplify the math basically.
OK, now we want to move on
to the problem of the day.
And the problem of the
day, I've written up here.
That's the last class's list.
We've got a motor,
fan or something.
It's got a rotating imbalance.
It's got a flexible base.
It's got a lot of
vertical vibration.
Driving you crazy.
The rotation rate--
this is a pump
or something with a rotating--
some rotating mass inside.
Has some eccentricity.
So it's causing
some external force.
Causing a force that results
in vertical vibration.
The rotation rate of
that fan is 1750 RPM.
The weight of this motor sitting
on this frame is 500 pounds.
When you set this motor and
bolt it down on that frame,
the frame deflects 0.026 inches.
And this thing's
vibrating like crazy.
Your assistant
comes in and says,
I got a solution for this.
We're going to put
braces in here,
and those braces will
double the K. The spring
constant of the thing.
And he or she asserts
that he thinks
it will cut the amplitude
of response in half.
Cut the vibration
amplitude in half.
So you're going to do
the calculation today
to see whether or not
this is a good idea.
And we're going to begin.
So assignment 1 is come up with
a simple lump parameter model--
masses, springs, dash,
pots-- of this system
so that you can model it.
So we've only been doing single
degree of freedom systems,
it's probably going to
look something like that.
So come up with a lump
parameter model of that,
and we've got what?
4, 8, 12.
We could do four groups easily
here of four or five each.
So break into four groups.
Come up first with
the-- and group 1--
we'll put group 1 right here.
And group 2 here,
and 3 and 4 there.
So come when you get-- when
your group figures this out.
And we got to move right
along because there's
several parts to this.
Just come up, sketch
your model that you're
going to do it with,
and then part 2 right
after that is to compute
the natural frequency
of the system.
We're going to eventually
have to compute the transfer
functions and then
try out the fix.
And see if the fix makes
things better or worse.
First assignment, come up
with a lump parameter model
and find the natural frequency.
Form your groups
and get talking.
AUDIENCE: Who's is this?
OK, guys, what about the force?
And what is it?
PROFESSOR: And it's really some
me omega squared cos omega t.
And this comes from the
equivalent little mass
on some arm, e going
around and around inside.
This is the equivalent
unbalanced mass here.
So keep coming up.
Put your models up here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You get the
[? mpd ?] [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, let's go back.
We've done this problem
about four times
over the course of homework.
And the term block with an
arm with a mass on the end.
The e is the length of the
arm, and the mass on the end
is essentially the
location of the center
of mass of the rotating part.
So the other three groups need
to draw a model up and come up
with the natural frequency.
One of the annoyances
of this problem
is it has nasty English units.
You all remember what
g is in English units?
I want radians per second.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but why do--
convert English inches to feet
and you're done.
Because you know g in
feet per second squared.
So rather than do three
conversions, do one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well that's
one, and then you know g.
So you can do it that way.
Sure.
I don't care.
I just want the result.
Which is group 1?
You guys are 1?
You got a number
you can give me?
How many MIT
students does it take
to convert from inches to feet?
AUDIENCE: We got that,
but we're not sure
if it's giving hertz
or radians afterwards.
PROFESSOR: Well,
in this equation,
does it give you
Hertz or radians?
Sure.
And you just made this
substitution in here.
So it hasn't done anything
to change to Hertz.
Write that down.
What a struggle!
OK.
Good.
That's good.
You can leave it.
All right.
We've all converged
to about 121.
That was quite a struggle.
Was it the units, or was
it-- partly was Hertz?
And you guys haven't had--
you're dealing with nothing
but equations for weeks.
And to actually have to do
real engineering numbers
has thrown you a little bit.
But so it's about 121.
And that g over delta
thing is really handy.
Now I want to know
what is the response
of this system to
this input given
the frequency of the
input is 1750 RPM?
And RPM, N is often
written, how is
it related to frequency in
Hertz or cycles per second?
Anybody know?
This is revolutions per minute.
What would be
revolution per second?
Is that same thing as Hertz?
So revolution is
something going around.
One full time around is 2 pi.
It's one cycle.
So if you do 60
cycles in a minute,
how many do you do in a second?
One.
So this RPM divided by 60
equals f in cycles per second.
Or Hertz.
RPM divided by 60 gives
you revolutions per second.
AUDIENCE: That says RPS.
PROFESSOR: Well, excuse me.
I was talking about--
get rid of that.
That's the relation you want.
And what's the relationship
between omega and f?
For every cycle, you
get 2 pi radians.
So now compute-- I want you to
give me an estimate-- find--
post my problem here.
So part 1 you've done.
Part 2 here and to get an
estimate of the magnitude
of this steady state response.
And we've been talking
about transfer functions.
So it's probably a replica
applying a transfer function
here.
I would put your
symbolic answer up
first would be a terrific idea.
Think you all-- when
you think you have kind
of a symbolic approach to this.
Go write it up, and that
way I can know where
you need a little help, if any.
That's OK.
So you don't know K.
So just leave that has
an undetermined quantity.
F0-- what is-- you guys
keep working for a second.
Then we'll talk about it.
You don't know K, so just
leave it as an unknown.
Don't do that.
Just call it F0.
But now plug in some numbers
for what you do know.
So one quantity
you're going to need
to make over omega n, so write
that one down when you get it.
What's omega over omega n,
and then move on from there.
Now there's a
little pitfall here
that you're all running into.
And that is you're taking
the positive square root as
written.
It's that whole
quantity down there.
Squared square root,
and you're writing
it 1 minus omega squared.
And this thing's going to
turn out negative on you
if you're not careful.
But you can flip it around.
It's really the absolute
value of that quantity,
because it a-- quantity squared
square root, so it can be
plus or minus.
So you got 1.54-- 1.5 what?
1.5 is your ratio?
OK, write it down.
Just write the ratio.
That's what you need.
1.5.
And you've got--
this is 4/5 here?
That's what you guys
have worked out?
OK, so 0.8.
AUDIENCE: How did they get 1.5?
PROFESSOR: They calculated
omega over omega n.
You have 183 divided by--
what was your omega n?
AUDIENCE: Oh, 60.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Not 60.
AUDIENCE: Well, no.
I mean it's like 360 over 260.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, you've got to divide
1750 by 60 to get F.
And then you got to
multiply by 2 pi.
I'm doing it for the benefit
of everybody in the room here.
0.8 F0 over K, all right.
Now we're getting somewhere.
0.8.
What do you guys have here?
You got 1 over 1.3.
How does that work out?
So about 0.8.
OK, so you've come
to the conclusion
that the magnitude of that study
state response is about 0.8 F0
over K.
And we call that F0
over K-- in lecture,
I call it the static response.
The book calls it
the static response.
Is it the same static response
as we're talking about here?
Don't confuse the two.
This was the effect of
gravity on the system.
The static response
we're talking about here
is if the frequency
of this excitation
went to 0, then
the response-- this
would stretch that spring
by the amount we're calling
xstatic, F0 over K. All right.
So now you know that you're
operating at a frequency.
What's the frequency
ratio that you found?
Omega over omega n.
That was an
intermediate step here.
All right, 1.5.
All right, now you're going
to-- the proposed fixed
is to double the stiffness.
Double the stiffness.
Now we want to
compute this result
if you double the stiffness.
And the person
who proposed that,
thinks it's going to
half the response.
That's the proposal.
So double the stiffness.
And in order to
get finished here,
what effect does changing the
stiffness have on this system?
AUDIENCE: Decreases
the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, you jump into
an answer-- intermediate step
here.
What does it do to
the natural frequency?
There's a natural
frequency change
if you change the stiffness.
OK, so the natural frequency is
normally some kind of K over m.
Now we also know
it's g over delta.
But we're going to
double the stiffness,
so what does that do to
the natural frequency?
Does the m change?
OK, so what's the--
this is omega n before.
Omega n after equals right.
OK.
And what does that do
to your frequency ratio?
So the effect of
changing the stiffness
changes the natural
frequency, and that
changes the ratio of
the input frequency
to the natural
frequency, and that
will change this
calculation here, right?
So come up with a
new value for this.
Anybody got a number?
What's the frequency
ratio after?
AUDIENCE: Uh, 1.1-- never mind.
I was doing the squared term.
PROFESSOR: I wanted to
know the frequency ratio.
This is after is
equal to the frequency
ratio that was something
to do with root 2 here.
The natural frequency is
going to go up or down
by a factor of root 2.
If you double K, the
natural frequency
will go up by a
square root of 2.
So the frequency ratio
after-- the natural frequency
goes up by the square root of 2.
That's the same as
root 2 over 2 here.
So the whole thing drops down.
So 1.5 times square
root of 2 over 2.
What is it?
All right.
1.07.
Now what is-- figure
out this quantity.
Pardon?
3.4.
And did you put in a 2 here?
Right.
So this is the correct
expression to be using.
But now in this new
problem-- this was before.
In this problem afterwards, x
is steady state is F0 over 2K
if double the stiffness,
all over this quantity omega
squared over omega
n squared minus 1,
but with the new
frequency ratio.
This is now 1.07.
You do this number,
what do you get?
3.-- what did that say?
3.4 roughly,
F0 over K. So you have
apples and apple together.
You want to compare the F0
over K before and after.
End it was a factor of 3.4.
So should you make the change?
No.
That's a bad idea.
You ran into a
situation like this
before, going to all that
trouble of cutting steel
and getting out the torch.
The welding system.
Take yourself a great big
weight and walk up, and thump
some weight on
top of this thing,
and see if it gets
better or worse.
Because if I double the mass of
the system, what would happen?
It's going to go
the other direction.
This will go up by
a factor of root 2.
And then this denominator--
you're pushing it further out.
And instead of being at
0.8, you'll be down further.